so we have coveted case data which shows
cases down 20
in the united states
what's going on all of a sudden as we've
been in this delta variant spike of the
coronavirus pandemic really for the last
three months daily
average new cases in the united states
are down 20 percent
just about every possible interpretation
is being put forward well it's more
vaccination that's responsible
there's some natural seasonality that's
responsible
we've had so many infections that
between the infections and the
vaccination we're closer to herd
immunity there's fewer people left for
the virus to infect that's been
suggested
uh cases aren't really going down it
only looks like they are because
reporting has become even less reliable
and states are lying or not fully
reporting case numbers that's another
possibility
we will discuss all of those uh
possibilities
but first the actual numbers
in this latest delta peak
cases peaked just shy of about 167 000
cases a day on september 2nd and have
since declined just shy of 20 percent to
about 134 000 cases per day
this is now more than nothing this is
not a statistical artifact there was the
idea well sir ma'am you had labor day
and uh the data was uh no now it is
clear that this is the full reporting of
the data
if states can be trusted which we will
get to but what's the meaning of this
now deaths which tend to move like cases
but on a three to four week delay
have leveled off right around about 1650
a day that's half a 9 11 a day still
um deaths might have turned the corner
and we might start to see a decline soon
or maybe not yet it's not really clear
it's sort of been like a leveling off
now globally by the way the same trend
is visible with cases which for the
delta wave cases peaked around
660 000 cases a day
that's now down globally to about 510
000 cases a day that's a similar decline
to the united states 22 to 23 percent
global case decline makes sense that the
global case decline would be a little
bit ahead of the united states decline
because the delta variant started in
europe they started to see declines
sooner all right so let's go through the
different possibilities is it possibly
vaccination that's responsible for this
case decline well it's possible
that it's having a partial impact
when the delta wave started picking up
in the united states
about 42 percent of the u.s was fully
vaccinated
now it's 55 percent of the u.s that's
fully vaccinated so that's a 13 point
increase but that's really an increase
of about 30 percent what i mean by that
is remember percent versus percentage
points when you go from 42 to 55 that's
an increase of about 30 so certainly
that's significant and that could be a
part of why we are starting to see this
case decline could seasonality that we
don't yet fully understand be a part of
it it could in the sense that we still
don't fully understand how seasonal
covet is remember when we spoke to
one of the country's top virologists
from columbia university vincent
racinello
he said yeah
there seems to be that to some degree
maybe although we don't fully understand
it and there's kind of the traditional
seasonality characteristics assigned to
flu
and we're not yet totally sure to what
degree they apply to kovid but there
seem to be these kind of natural peaks
and valleys that develop
we don't 100 understand why although we
do understand some of it so that's a
possibility
the third possibility
is it that more and more people in total
have antibodies between the infected and
the vaccinated yeah to some degree
that's a possibility as well officially
there have been 43 million cases in the
u.s now
there's no way that number is right why
well first of all the 43 million
isn't necessarily 43 million individuals
in the sense that 43 million could
include people who had more than one
positive test throughout the pandemic it
also doesn't include the asymptomatic
people that never got tested the real
number might be 80 million it might be
70 million it's really not clear but
you've got that and then you've got 55
of the country vaccinated there's
obviously overlap some people who got
coveted are also vaccinated so
we don't really know the number of
people with antibodies right now but you
could be seeing a
sort of higher and higher level of
antibodies that may be
giving the virus um kind of less uh less
dry tinder so to speak and then lastly
are these numbers just inaccurate are
these numbers artificially low
because states are lying or they're not
testing enough i'm not testing enough
absolutely when you see states with a
high positivity rate it means you're not
testing enough you're almost certainly
not capturing
every positive case
in terms of straight up lying i mean
yeah maybe
um we know about florida's deceptive
reporting on deaths although eventually
they report the numbers we think but on
a 7 to 10 day delay so that could be to
some degree a part of it as well so
this appears to be a real decline not
related to holiday data
whether it looks bigger than it really
is because of inaccurate
uh
incomplete or dishonest reporting from
states
we don't know and of course the hope is
that it continues
last year remember as we got into the
fall um wait oh it's the fall right i
mean yeah yeah yesterday was the last
day of summer i think what year is it i
don't know what's going on i think it's
now the fall last year in the fall we
were expecting just a massive massive
spike
and we got it and we got it um and then
it peaked right around january uh right
around inauguration day actually right
around january 20th 19th 21st
maybe we won't see that this time around
uh but in the midst of all this the
it's not really a new conspiracy theory
but the conspiracy theory that coveted
vaccines are killing people has found
new energy and i want to talk about that
next
later in the show
i'm going to have clips for you
of fox news propagandist tucker carlson
who almost certainly has been vaccinated
for a really long time
uh spreading the debunked
unsubstantiated claim
that vaccines might be killing thousands
of people now i've been getting calls
from people
for a year at this point or uh not no
not quite that's an exact eight months
or so
saying david the coveted vaccine is
killing people this has been floating
around for a while
but it's really growing now um just as
one
it's mostly happening on facebook but
just as a reminder here's video we
looked at last week this was the gavin
newsom joe biden rally the day before
the california recall this is the
california recall last tuesday which
went horribly wrong for republicans and
you've got to listen closely but one of
the arguments happening outside was with
a woman claiming that more people died
from the covet vaccine than from the flu
take a listen to this
so just give it time remember the woman
on the right is the woman arguing about
the economy air force mom in the blue
shirt is the one spreading the vaccine
death conspiracies it's gonna focus in
on her in a moment
is
and the these audio problems are in the
clip i apologize
in less than one year
in less than one
[Music]
so this is getting a lot of attention
and it's important to remind you that
there is no evidence that people are
dying from the vaccine so politifact um
flags this as having
sort of started with facebook posts on
august 24th
it's older than that but okay for the
purposes of today uh the claim was
hundreds of thousands died after taking
the advice of these celebrities who were
aiding and abetting mass murder by
advocating vaccination now
the if your time is short summary
from politifact is
there is no evidence of covet vaccines
causing deaths
according to the cdc there is no
evidence that covid19 vaccines have
caused any deaths in the united states
this was then updated
um
there is a 24-minute video slamming
celebrities for recommending the
vaccines
says the vaccines have killed hundreds
of thousands of people
the text at the start of the video says
quote you may never trust another
celebrity after watching this video
hundreds of thousands died after taking
the advice of these celebrities should
they be tried for murder
aiding and abetting mass murder through
vaccination all for population control
uh facebook did ultimately take that
down
um
and as the article points out kovit has
killed nearly 675 000 in the u.s and
more than four and a half million
worldwide the vaccines authorized in the
us have been shown to significantly
reduce the likelihood of severe illness
hospitalization and death and no
evidence has established that a coveted
vaccine authorized in the u.s
has caused any deaths let alone hundreds
of thousands i think it's important to
be precise there
we really don't know what's going on
with some of these other vaccines in
other countries
they haven't been evaluated by the
american fda and the reporting around
their side effects
is is
you know incomplete at best so we're not
saying anything one way or the other i
have no reason to think the russian
vaccine or the chinese vaccine or
killing people i have family in
argentina that have gotten those
vaccines the article though is being
specific and precise
saying the vaccines authorized in the
united states
uh we have no evidence to suggest that
those are killing people so
unfortunately
you know when the situation escalates
the conspiracy theories seem to escalate
as well and now they're just straight up
saying hundreds of thousands dead from
the vaccines without any evidence
whatsoever later in the show we are
going to talk about tucker carlson
signal boosting this false claim
and we're going to talk about how easy
it is
i i didn't do it but i went through and
started going through the process to see
how easy it is it is so easy to submit a
false vaccine side effect claim
up to and including death in what's
called the veyers system v-a-e-r-s
that you may well have reports of deaths
that are unsubstantiated as well so
we're gonna get to that a little bit
later
if you know people in your personal life
who are who are repeating this one
thousands dead hundreds of thousands
dead from the vaccines
i want to hear from you okay find me on
twitter at deepakman or shoot us an
email info davidpakman.com
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
remember that the david pakman show is
made possible by viewers and listeners
who sign up on our website and get a
membership we do a commercial free audio
and video version of the show for our uh
members we also do an extra show every
day called the bonus show only for you
you can get instant access by signing up
at joinpacman.com
okay before the break i talk to you
about
the um conspiracy theory with new life
essentially which it's not any it's not
it's gone from i guess i would say
some people have really bad side effects
to the vaccine
um do we know for sure that the vaccine
hasn't killed anyone they've now gone to
the vaccines for covet have killed
thousands of people
tens of thousands of people or even
hundreds of thousands of people that's
the new conspiracy now tucker carlson
fox news propagandist is a guy who's
been i wouldn't even really call it
playing coy the only aspect of it that's
coy is that tucker is almost certainly
vaccinated
and works at fox news which has stricter
vaccination guidelines than joe biden
proposed two weeks ago to the united
states remember
joe biden's um plan uh his directive
is if you've got more than 100 employees
everybody either has to be vaccinated
or has to test weekly okay
fox's policy is
you've got to be vaccinated and submit
your vaccination information or
you've got to test daily and you've got
to wear masks at fox news facilities so
while on air tucker and others are
attacking the biden plan on vaccination
requirements fox they work for fox which
has a stricter plan so okay tucker he's
almost certainly uh been vaccinated he
was probably first in line as soon as he
could get it maybe even got it early all
right so tucker has gone now
from repeating
i hate i don't even know that i want to
use the word milder but
repeating somewhat milder
conspiracies about vaccines
to now repeating the debunked claim that
thousands might be dying from
vaccinations media matters has the
coverage
and says during the september 20
broadcast of tucker tonight
tucker railed against the vaccine
requirement for active duty service
members lying that thousands could have
died that thousands have died from the
vaccine in a segment that included
claims that the vaccination requirements
are a ploy to weed out and expel sincere
christians in the ranks the free
thinkers the men with high testosterone
levels and anyone else who does not love
joe biden and accusations that the u.s
military runs pr for satanism
carlson claimed that a presentation
given to members of the army quote
falsely claims that only three people
have died from the vaccine carlson then
told viewers that reports collected by
the biden administration itself indicate
the number is actually in the thousands
all right i'm going to explain that in a
moment let's listen very dangerous
propaganda white supremacy in the
military is a crisis said the most
unscrupulous people in washington but
that's not what it was about
what you just saw on tape was in fact a
power grab the message
no one who does not support our
political party is allowed to bear arms
that's what they're saying very clearly
and because it's the democratic party
doing the talking here there was also
needless to say a vicious racial angle
too because there always is right watch
congressman steve cohen of tennessee
explain
the guard is
90 some odd percent i believe
male 1 um
only about 20 of white males voted for
bible you got to figure that in the
guard which is predominantly more
conservative and i see that on my social
media and we know it they're probably
not more than 25 of the people
that are there protecting us who voted
for biden the other 75 percent are in
the class that would be uh the large
class of folks who might want to
do something
so if you're white you're dangerous says
a sitting member of congress that clip
was from january of course that was the
same month that lloyd austin announced
he was cracking down on this extremism
then a few months later january was the
same month as something else too i just
don't remember what what else happened
in january later reading from the same
song sheet mark millie told the us
congress he was working to root out
white rage in the military
okay
and yet after all of this because we're
keeping score as of today we're not
aware of a single white supremacist on
active duty who has been discovered by
the pentagon and fired not one
so that threat didn't exist
interestingly would we even know if
that's the case i mean are our discharge
uh proceedings typically made public i
mean it's not clear it's a question at
minimum at all it was fake that was all
a lie
several national guard troops were
relieved of duty around the inauguration
that no one has ever explained why they
were fired
then a senior commander in the space
force lieutenant colonel matthew
lohmeier lost his job and we know why
his crime was criticizing marxism that's
a firing offense now
then in august lloyd austin came up with
a new political purity test
this one was specifically designed to
separate the obedient from the free
can't have any of the latter category
austin said he planned to fire anyone in
the entire armed services who would not
submit to the covet 19 vaccination shot
so tucker now building to the case that
there should be no mandatory vaccination
in the military and then going on to say
some really really wacky things here
let's continue
that would get the democratic party
nothing
the point of mandatory vaccination is to
identify the sincere christians in the
ranks the free thinkers the men with
high testosterone levels and anyone else
who does not love joe biden and make
them leave immediately it's a takeover
of the us military here's how they're
doing it
this show has just obtained a powerpoint
that the army is using to justify
mandatory vaccines to the troops this is
an actual slide from it on your screen
you will notice there the sympathetic
portrayal of satanism
how many children were sacrificed to
satan because the vaccine the slide
reads apparently sarcastically
then the first presentation proceeds to
list the so-called tenants of satanism
which are taken straight from the temple
of satanism website
so here you have the united states army
doing pr for satanism
the rest of the presentation is less
shocking that but it's utterly shoddy
and dishonest for example it falsely
claims that only three people have died
from taking the covet vaccine
reports collected by the biden
administration itself indicate that
number is actually in the thousands okay
so that is not true
in the in even remotely the sense that
tucker carlson is saying it
the false reporting on the vares system
which anybody can submit
is then called biden administration data
that's being collected the website just
exists it was there under trump and it
was there it continues to be there under
joe biden and then the false or at least
unchecked reporting of side effects and
death surveyors
is used to say stuff like what tucker
just said now i'm not going to pull it i
don't want to encourage anyone to submit
a false report
but you can go and look at the vayer
system and start the process of
submitting a report don't do it i did it
up until the point at which i would have
submitted it and i started typing in
david pakman you know sir david pakman
died from the vaccine treated by this
doctor you know whatever
you can just submit it anybody can
submit the information and it's being
taken as quote proof by the anti-vaxx to
say that all of these people are dying
they take it as gospel evidence
because it's a government website but
they're ignoring the fact that it's not
verified
anybody can show up and report anything
and then it's part of the reporting it
doesn't mean that these are verified
vetted or confirmed instances of vaccine
issues problems or whatever the case may
be there's no validation required there
now
i think it's worth mentioning
even if it were true that thousands died
from the vaccine now i like i hesitate
to even do this because it's such a can
of worms but
if it's true that
let's call it 3000. imagine 3000 people
died from the vaccine not true but just
imagine
you're still way more likely to die of
covet as a healthy person than of the
vaccine
i'm not saying it would be okay if
thousands of people died from the
vaccine but if thousands of people died
from the vaccine
out of the 182 million fully vaccinated
people that would mean you have a
0.0016 chance of dying from the vaccine
that's 500 times smaller than your
chance of dying from the virus
if it were true we would have to really
think about that but it's not true
importantly it's not true so it's tucker
again
being extremely irresponsible about
vaccines um and then also recently just
just to kind of just show you the full
circle on how irresponsible he's being
he also said brazilian president jair
bolsonaro doesn't need to be vaccinated
because he had covid this is not true
but this is tucker claiming it okay put
them in place
not some restaurant is just following
his orders
so de blasio just issued a warning to
brazil's president jared bolsonaro he
told us bolster not to come to the u.n
general assembly because
he's not vaccinated yeah
we need to send a message to all the
world leaders including most notably
bolsonaro from brazil that if you intend
to come here you need to be vaccinated
if you don't want to be vaccinated don't
bother coming because everyone should be
safe together
really because bolsonaro already
recovered from covid so he doesn't need
the vaccine no one who's recovered from
covid needs the vaccine they have
greater immunity than people who get the
vaccine this is insane that is not true
that is a lie what's insane is that
tucker is repeating these things we now
have multiple studies which show
you are more likely to be reinfected
if you've had covid and don't get the
vaccine
than if you do get the vaccine okay it
is not true what tucker is saying
what is apparently true
is that if you're vaccinated and
recovered from covid you have stronger
immunity than if you were merely
vaccinated alone it's not a reason to go
out and try to get covet but there are
studies which say
recovery plus vaccination is better than
vaccination alone a lot of caveats
depends on timing did you recover from
one of the earlier strains or did you
recover from a later there's all these
different caveats but what tucker is
saying is absolutely wrong
and this gets us to the next story which
is that of the brazilian unvaccinated
president
this is really really wacky
um as tucker told us in the last segment
new york city mayor bill de blasio did
say
to brazilian president yair bolsonaro
don't come to new york if you're not
vaccinated you gotta you gotta be
vaccinated to go into places don't do it
don't don't don't do it
um bolsonaro spoke yesterday at the u.n
um apparently he's supposed to keep his
mask on all the time because he's not
vaccinated as far as we know now it's
also possible he actually is vaccinated
but this is all you know
his political uh posturing we don't
actually know but let's assume he's
really not vaccinated i believe he's
supposed to keep his mask on all the
time he took it off during his un speech
anyway what i absolutely love
is that because new york city has this
requirement for vaccination to eat
indoors at restaurants
there are now pictures of bolsonaro and
his entourage
standing outside of a pizza shop
um
eating pizza on the sidewalk
because he's not allowed into
restaurants and it actually seems like
this was a really good idea because his
health minister who traveled to the
united states with him has tested
positive
the new york post reporting on this i
know the new york post brazil's
unvaccinated president was spotted this
weekend eating pizza on a sidewalk in
new york city where tourists and
residents who are unvaccinated for the
virus are barred from eating indoors
bolsonaro was pictured with several
other members of his delegation in an
instagram post monday by
gilson machado netto brazil's minister
for tourism
the photo was captioned let's go for
pizza with coca-cola the brazilian
president is the only g20 leader who has
not been vaccinated for the virus has
repeatedly defended his decision citing
his battle with covid last year why take
the vaccine to have antibodies isn't
that right my antibody levels are way up
high now as a reminder um uh if you are
recovered from kovid you should still
get vaccinated the immunity and antibody
levels are much higher if you get
vaccinated um we talked about that last
segment and it bears repeating but
here's where it gets really interesting
brazil's health minister tests positive
for kovid
in new york city
um which guy is this in the picture is
this guy in the picture i can't even
tell is it one of these oh i think is it
this guy back uh over the shoulder um
look at this brazil's health minister
marcelo kiroga tested positive for kovid
hours after accompanying president jair
bolsonaro to the u.n general assembly on
tuesday
kiroga will remain in new york on
quarantine the government's
communications office said the minister
is doing well the rest of the delegation
tested negative kiroga told cnn brazil
he wore a mask the entire time he was in
the u.n building
bolsonaro vaccine skeptic defied u.n
rules that'll ask all those attending to
be vaccinated he is bragged about not
getting vaccinated this is absolutely
and utterly insane
what is good
well
i guess what we could say that's good is
bolsonaro is not looking so good in the
polls uh in brazil and it would be a
really great thing to remove this guy in
a humiliating and absolutely uh uh
embarrassing way let's hope that that
happens
um and uh what what a just pathetic guy
i mean it really is like brazilian trump
in many many ways we'll have more
coverage of this on our instagram find
us on instagram at david pakman show
back right after this
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow alright let's get to a
couple of wacky things in different ways
this memo has now leaked this is a memo
from donald trump's lawyer
with a plan a six-point plan for how
they wanted to overturn the result of
the 2020 election this memo is
remarkable
but for more than one reason it's
remarkable because of the audacity of
thinking to do this
it's also remarkable because it makes
clear to me that they know this is all
bs they know trump didn't actually win
and it's also remarkable because i
wonder
had someone even more absurd than mike
pence uh been president of vice
president at the time
is there a chance not that it would have
actually kept trump in office but that
it might have led to
even more chaos uh if the vice president
had been willing to at least try some of
this stuff so the international business
times reporting
leaked memo shows how trump's lawyer
wanted pence to overturn elections
the leaked memo outlined six steps pence
could take to declare trump the winner
of the election the memo included plans
to overthrow the electoral college votes
from seven states pence argued the
constitution did not give him power to
overturn the results this is all
outlined in the book peril
which explains that conservative lawyer
john eastman allegedly sent a two-page
memo outlining these steps
at the end he announces that because of
the ongoing disputes in the seven states
there are no electors that can be deemed
validly appointed in those states
meaning the total number of electors
appointed is 454.
a majority of those appointed would be
228 and trump would have 232 of them now
we're gonna look at the six point plan
in detail in a moment
some of these details are wild which
includes that the proposal was first
given to pence on january four two days
before the the riot when trump attempted
to convince the then president the then
vice president that he had the authority
to overturn it you really need to listen
to john he's a respected constitutional
scholar hear him out trump told pence
however pence refused to intervene
saying he doesn't have that authority
and then this is maybe the craziest
detail on january 6th hours before the
riot pence told trump constitution
doesn't let me do it and that led trump
to hold their friendship hostage no no
no trump shouted you don't understand
mike you can do this i don't want to be
your friend anymore if you don't do this
so let's look at the six-point plan
okay step one
pence presiding over the joint session
uh or senate pro temp grassley if pence
recuses begins to open and count ballots
starting with alabama without conceding
that the procedure specified by the
electoral account act of going through
the states alphabetically is required
when he gets to arizona he announces he
has multiple slates of electors and so
is going to defer decision
until uh on that until finishing the
other states this would be the first
break with the procedure set out in the
act so this is an idea we talked about
before they were talking about you just
send different electors send send
republican electors
step three
at the end
he announces that because of the ongoing
disputes in seven states there are no
electors that can be deemed validly
appointed in those states that means the
total number of electors appointed the
language of the 12th amendment is 454.
this reading of the 12th amendment has
also been advanced by harvard law
professor lawrence tribe a majority of
the electors appointed would therefore
be 228 if you reduce the number of
appointed electors you reduce what it
counts as 50 percent plus one
uh there are at this point 232 for trump
222 for biden pence gavels president
trump as re-elected
howells of course from the democrats who
now claim contrary to tribe's prior
position that 270 is required so pence
says fine pursuant to the 12th amendment
no candidate has achieved the necessary
majority that sends the matter to the
house where the votes shall be taken by
states the representation from each
state having one vote republicans
currently control 26 state delegations
president trump is re-elected there as
well
step five one last piece assuming the
electoral count act process is followed
and upon getting the objections to the
arizona slates the two houses break into
separate chambers we should not allow
that the electoral count act constraint
on debate to control
that would mean that a prior legislature
was determining the rules of the present
one a constitutional no no so someone
ted cruz rand paul should demand normal
rules which includes the filibuster that
creates a stalemate and it would give
the state legislatures more time to
weigh in to formally support the
alternate slate of electors if they
haven't already done so
and finally step six
the main thing here is that pens should
do this without asking for permission
either from a vote of the joint session
or from the court
let the other side challenge his actions
in court oh sorry and the the zoom just
went crazy let me get resumed in here
uh number six
um let the other side challenge his
actions in court where tribe who
conceded in 2001 the president of the
senate might be in charge of counting
the votes and others who would press a
lawsuit that these are non-justiceable
justiceable political questions thrown
back at them
um okay yeah anyway step six is like so
far out there that it's not even even as
relevant
although this is completely absurd and
ludicrous
imagine if donald trump had had someone
as his vice president willing to try
like pence just said i'm not even gonna
i'm not even gonna try because i can't
do it
i still believe it would not have
succeeded but it would have caused a
hell of a lot of chaos in the process
and then you know i know these terms are
hyperbolic the terms i'm about to use
if they had pulled off what would have
been a coup
could it have launched a civil war of
sorts like
what would actually happen
if this had been attempted
and then they would have used that to
say look at how violent the left is
um an absolutely insane six step plan i
guess it feels weird to say this but i
guess in some way
we should be glad it was pence and not
someone even crazier like marge vp
marjorie taylor green almost certainly
tries this
vp matt gates
probably tries this it still fails but
it might cause insane chaos and violence
in so doing
hey this is really weird video
of bill gates being interviewed by pbs
news's judy woodruff
about his meetings and relationship with
the late jeffrey epstein
and bill gates
seems super nervous and when asked if
there's a lesson here
bill gates says
well he's dead
um
i'm not a conspiracy guy you guys all
know that you know i i'm not making any
claim about the circumstances of jeffrey
epstein's that i i just i'm not i don't
believe bill gates is involved in a
pedophile ring as some q anon people
like to say
this is just bizarre video of bill gates
seeming so nervous and uncomfortable
it could just be because he knows that
he had a relationship at least a
temporary one with a guy who ended up
being a really really bad guy
and then when asked about the lesson he
says well he's dead
it's a crazy video let's take a look at
it it was reported at that time
that you had a number of meetings with
jeffrey epstein who when you met him 10
years ago he was convicted of soliciting
prostitution from minors
what did you know about him when you
were meeting with him as you've said
yourself
in the hopes of raising money
uh you know i had
dinners with him uh
i
regret doing that
he had relationships with uh people he
said you know would give to global
health which is uh now notice that gates
doesn't answer the question from judy
woodruff which is what did you know
about his run-ins with the law at the
time of your meetings gates just says he
claimed to know people that wanted to
donate but he's not actually answering
what he knew about epstein at the time
uh interest i have you know not nearly
enough philanthropy goes in that
direction
uh you know those meetings were were a
mistake they didn't result in
uh what he purported and i cut them off
you know that goes back a long
time ago now uh there's you know so
there's nothing new on that it was
reported that you continued to meet with
him over several years
um
and that in other words a number of
meetings
um
what did you do when you found out about
his
background
well
and you know i've said i regretted
having those dinners uh and there's
nothing absolutely nothing new on that
is there a lesson for you for
anyone else looking looking at this
well he's dead so
uh
you know in general you always have to
be careful what does that mean i mean
genuinely what does that mean well he's
d what was the lesson to bill gates
about the fact that he met with someone
who either he knew had a background of
soliciting minors for prostitution
or and he still met with him or he
didn't know because he hadn't looked
into it and his team like either way
there might be a lesson for bill gates
but bill gates is like bully's dead
and you know the
you know i'm i'm
very proud of what we've done in
philanthropy very proud of the work of
the foundation
uh
you know
that's
that's what i get up every day and focus
on yeah so listen i i you guys know me
i'm not a conspiracy theorist i don't
think bill gates is involved in a child
pedophile ring i don't think bill gates
is trying to track people with vaccines
i think if every billionaire um
behaved more like bill gates and less
like you know i don't know who somebody
else i think the we would be better off
we would be better off if that was the
case i think bill gates done a lot of
great things what he's been doing on
sanitation in africa
period it's just a bizarre interview and
when asked what lesson did you learn
saying well he's dead and you got to be
careful it's almost like it
is what's he saying what's he saying
about epstein or himself i don't
understand it it's very strange it's uh
sort of delightfully uncomfortable in
some strange way
i'd be curious to hear from you
what do you make of it and i can't
imagine bill gates looking or sounding
any more uncomfortable any more
uncomfortable some people are saying
well gates is just lying i think that
it's obvious that he's not answering the
questions being asked i mean the first
question is what did you know about
epstein's criminal past at the time you
met with him and gates says well i met
with him because he said he he had
donors for the things i'm working on
um
and then
when asked about uh
what you know do you regret it he said
well it didn't lead to any donations so
it's almost like he's saying had it led
to donations it would be fine despite
the criminal it's all weird i'm curious
to hear from you what you make of it
subscribe to our youtube channel at
the
youtube.com
pakman show watch the full hour-long
show individual clips all of our
interviews and everything else from the
show and when you subscribe make sure to
click that bell button to be notified
about every new video
i want to call your attention back to
that really wacky lawyer sydney powell
who
was working with donald trump on his
fraud claims after the 2020 election and
then wasn't and then it was said when
she went seemingly completely crazy
that she's acting on her own but she was
at the white house meeting with trump in
the oval office that lady sydney powell
she now appeared on one of these
completely wacky shows
and claims that democrats
killed an aide to then senator kelly
leffler
who died in a car accident now you might
remember this story
back during that um special election
where you had
um both david perdue and kelly lefler in
georgia facing special senate elections
um a 20 year old staffer of kelly
leffler's campaign
died in a car crash and it was a really
crazy thing where it was like the day or
the day before a rally
and i'm trying to remember lefleur maybe
missed a rally as a result of it or
something like that you go back and you
look at the stories kelly lefler herself
tweeting it is with extremely heavy with
an extremely heavy heart that we mourn
the loss of harrison deal
my heart aches for his family
and jeff and i will continue to surround
them in love and prayer in the days
ahead
harrison was a beloved member of our
campaign team
the
accident was a multi-vehicle accident in
south georgia ah and it forced lefler
and kemp brian kemp to cancel their
plans to join mike pence in savannah
for a rally
um
[Music]
okay so
sidney powell
goes on some show and refers to that as
democrats blowing up
one of kelly lefler's staffer's cars
it's not only absolutely insane and
completely unsubstantiated
isn't it kind of disrespectful to the
family of harrison deal as well not that
not that people like sydney uh powell
care about stuff like that let's listen
free of that
i think what we are dealing with here is
pervasive
and very very dark
it's organized it's well-funded
is she talking about the plot to steal
the election it's
pure evil
they are willing to kill people
a la kelly lefler's aide in georgia who
was suddenly blown up
in his car on the way to a rally
that's crazy that's completely insane i
hope people understand the degree to
which that is absurd
for her
he happened to be dating governor kemp's
daughter
governor kemp was considering i think at
that point a signature audit
and then the georgia bureau of
investigation agent who was
investigating that he was the lead
investigator was suddenly dead within a
week
and suddenly we don't hear anything else
about any of that
we are talking about trillions of
dollars of global wealth at issue here
the leadership and control of the of the
most powerful country on the face of the
earth how insane is this woman
um some of you might remember
she was interviewed by i believe it was
an australian media outlet a couple of
weeks ago and we covered it
and she genuinely seems delusional i'm i
am not joking like she seems to have no
connection to reality whatsoever this
actually was a little bit of a
conspiracy theory that started spreading
before um the facebook post on december
5th claimed joe biden killed
the kelly lefler staffer
um
and as politifact points out harrison
deal a campaign staffer for senator
kelly leffler died after a three-vehicle
collision
a spokesperson for the police department
in the town where it happened said a
flatbed truck struck diel's vehicle from
behind
causing him to hit another vehicle
and there is just no evidence that joe
biden was involved and what's really
crazy about these stories
is that
the story starts to get some oxygen
to the point where someone will want to
put out like a fact check
and then the fact that it gets fact
checked
becomes part of the conspiracy like you
and i might read that and say oh okay
it's like in really clear and simple
terms
there is no actual evidence that there
was foul play here that joe biden killed
kelly lefler staffer that this was a
murder there's just there's just no
evidence of it you and i might see it
that way but the believers will see
the fact check as part of the conspiracy
and this is a really common tenet uh
some people call it a tenant like when
they say pundits god that pisses me off
okay anyway it's a tenet t-e-n-e-t uh
one of the tenets of conspiracism
is that
once you've generated the conspiracy
theory
uh evidence for it supports your belief
in it
evidence against it supports your belief
in it because obviously the evidence
against it is planted
not finding evidence supports your
belief in it because the evidence must
have been covered up or hidden and you
get into this circle of conspiracism and
some people can never get out you know
trump talks about flushing toilets 10 or
15 times you just you can't flush your
way out of this it just stays there and
it lingers and it lingers
and there's really no way out of it so
there's sydney powell
very very dangerous woman a disgusting
woman um and someone who seems to be
dealing with some pretty serious issues
uh of her own i think we can say quite
frankly
we have another one folks a couple known
as the alabama pickers i had no idea who
these people were a couple known as the
alabama pickers a reality show couple
known for youtube videos where they
resell tchotchkes as i like to call them
they have both died of kovid
this is incredible and of course now
they leave children behind
with no parents
um alabama pickers as reported by al.com
couple known for reselling
and known for vaccine opposition both
dead of covet
a married alabama couple known for their
reselling videos on youtube i guess what
this means is
you go to these
um self storage units
and you buy
stuff that's unclaimed and then you
resell it like i guess that's what what
they do
um they have both died of covid they are
known on youtube as the alabama pickers
dusty and tristan graham lived in
huntsville where they would often post
videos about tips and tricks to
reselling vintage items
like clothes and home decor
on ebay under the username bama 4348
dusty died thursday almost three weeks
after his wife did
according to the gofundme page set up by
one of their children
one of the most tragic lines in news
articles that exists
is
according to the gofundme page set up
by one of their children it's tragic
generally
and it's extra tragic because of what it
says about the american healthcare
system as well
the article goes on to say this is what
windsor graham wrote
unfortunately dusty and tristan have
both passed away
thank you all for your kind words and
helping us during this difficult time we
will be using the money
to pay for funeral expenses
one of the last
videos the married couple posted on
their now deleted youtube channel
was about how they wouldn't get the
vaccine
it was later reposted to vax man's
channel
which is connected to a website titled
sorry
anti-vaxxer.com
dedicated to sharing stories of people
who have gotten coveted and died or came
close to dying after sharing anti-vaxx
beliefs
dusty says in the video at the
mark quote i've got my own passport it's
called the bill of rights
i think this will be all behind us in a
couple years
dusty later spelled out the word vaccine
and said it was actually a form of
immunity therapy they were giving people
the pair then talked about everything
they had survived already
including bone cancer in tristan's case
they talked about covid and the vaccine
at length on their channel
tristan died on august 25th in her sleep
two days later dusty started a gofundme
for her while he was still in the icu
anything you can find in your heart will
be so appreciated dusty wrote a week ago
their daughter windsor wrote in a now
deleted facebook post dusty was moving
to a ventilator and to continue praying
the gofundme goal is currently 35 000
and just over 20 000 has been raised for
the couple
um let's get an update on that gofundme
uh yeah 25 25 000.
this is horrifying guys i i i don't like
this you know it's another kid now both
parents both parents and they were they
were relatively young
um
also you know on the crowd funding the
gofundme stuff for medical bills and
funeral expenses
there's something odd about how crowd
funding for medical bills is fine
but socialized health care that prevents
the need for that is bad to these people
and i think a lot of it is that you know
they say we should do things through
charity rather than government mandate
and so they may actually defend they
would say no it actually makes sense we
don't want the government saying health
care for everyone but then if people out
of the kindness of their hearts want to
give us money for medical bills or the
funeral then then that would be fine um
i have a couple of friends who have a
business that relates to peanut farming
and uh it has nothing to do with jimmy
carter but it does relate to peanut
farming they've been spending a lot of
time in alabama where the alabama
pickers are or were from as well as
georgia and they told me last week um
that it's like there's no pandemic there
it's just like there's no pandemic
taking place there at all
and uh they when they go inside to
offices and stuff at these peanut farms
where they're doing certain type of
consulting for
uh they're the only ones wearing masks
and not only is nobody wearing a mask
some of these states have only 40 40 to
44 vaccination so it's really bad down
there really really bad and here are
more orphans more orphans as a result
statistically speaking of anti-vaxxerism
we can't say for sure
that these parents would be alive had
they been vaccinated
but statistically speaking
almost certainly at least one of them
would be had they both been vaccinated
unless there's something very specific
that we just don't know
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p
this is absolutely great
um a viewer left a voicemail
and it is a parody of eric from
massachusetts eric from massachusetts is
a guy who's been calling me for the
entire pandemic saying david you're
going to end up in prison thanks to the
vaccine stuff that you're promoting on
your show so here is a parody of eric
from massachusetts then i'll play for
you the real eric from massachusetts
hey david this is uh curtis for mass
hey i mean i hate it i hate to break it
to you david i mean i told you i mean
these vaccines are just like you know
they don't work
i mean i live here in massachusetts we
have one of the highest
fully vaccinated rates in the country
and you know consistently
the lowest rate of hospitalization and
the lowest rate of deaths and the lowest
rate of infections
i mean these vaccines david they just
don't work you should be
arrested and imprisoned uh for all of
the misinformation that you're spreading
all right so that's pretty spot on and
as a reminder here's the real eric from
massachusetts with his admonishments to
me
hey david it's eric from mass
very similar i have to say just
wondering uh
a few things um i on your videos earlier
you were uh touting the vaccines that
they're
all this uh 98
effect this that the other and
now um everyone else should get it
vaccinated but if aren't you admitting i
mean seriously think about this aren't
you admitting that the vaccines don't
work if you're saying everyone else
needs them i mean just think about that
no that's been the case with every
vaccine i mean when you take the measles
vaccine the measles vaccine is very
effective but measles is so contagious
that you really need almost everybody to
be vaccinated we understand these things
it's simple math we are now learning
about immunity waning over time uh these
things are not uh unexpected um you know
but it's it's this guy's really obsessed
with this stuff i mean if you have a
better
way of telling
people me and everyone explain explain
why
if they work so well why everyone else
should do it because nothing is 100
and there are actually people
who can't get the vaccine including
right now everybody under 12. so we do
it because we care about other people
but we need people to be team players
it's like how are we in uh september of
2021
still not understanding this eric i mean
i just
if you can convince me of that you know
what go on your show you can convince me
of a reason
that i should get it
when it's obviously not working i'll get
it okay eric the problem is you're
saying i'll get vaccinated if you
convince me of something you either
refuse to accept or won't understand
because at this point in september of
2021 i don't know
i don't know what else could possibly be
done or said let me put it that way
we're going to have a great bonus show
today on the bonus show today we are
going to talk about
is it true
that when it's a missing white girl like
gabby petito
there is more news attention paid than
when it is a non-white girl or woman
okay we're going to talk about that on
today's show we have data we have math
we have stats all right
we are also going to talk today on the
bonus show about the house build that
would blow up the huge iras of the super
wealthy we've talked before in the
context of how the hell did mitt romney
get so much money in his ira
when you can only contribute a few
thousand bucks a year how how did he do
it
uh we're going to talk about the house
bill that would change that and lastly
amazon is now lobbying the us government
to make pot legal
what's in it for them i will explain it
to you it's actually quite interesting
all of those stories that i just
mentioned and more are on today's bonus
show the bonus show is available
instantly for everybody who signs up at
joinpakman.com
or makes a pledge of at least five bucks
a month on patreon
at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow sign up and we will see
you on the bonus show